wind signaling pathway is an important
self-signaling pathway it is involved in
development is homeostasis and disease
in absence of ligand wind receptors are
bound to a complex known as destruction
complex which is composed of axine APC
jsk 3 beta ck1 Alpha Etc
beta-catinine gets phosphorylated by
this particular destruction complex and
phosphorylated beta-catinine can be
degraded by a proteosome when the ligand
is present beta-catinine is free and
non-phosphorylated in this situation
beta-catinine can translocate into the
nucleus and can start gene expression it
can interact with complexes like TCF and
LIF which lead to Gene activation
and this is how the wind signaling
pathway operates in presence and absence
of ligand